if you had told me years ago that mike
Mayock would be a general manager of the
Oakland Raiders and he would be
threatened by Antonio Brown and the
Raiders would still let him play a game
on Monday Night Football as Jon Gruden
just announced moments ago I'd say
you're crazy but that just actually
happened and so we'll keep an eye on
that situations as conditions warrant if
I'd told you that I would have a show
with my own name on it entering its
fifth year and I would turn to my right
and I'd have as a guest one mr. Craig
Kilborn I'd say you're just as crazy but
yet both are true good to see you thank
you created Kilbourne it is a joy to be
here how is it going so far
your what our chat so far by the way
it's swimmingly it's going swimmingly
right now
I don't women the last time we saw each
other where is it is it in the 90s it's
gotta be when I think you were the host
of the cable ACE Awards sure had to have
been it may have been that very moment
so that may have been like ninety seven
or eight or something didn't that it's
been that long well you look great
got you man it's good to see you can I
quickly tell I told you something off
the air okay I think America should hear
it Thank You curry I worked with two
broadcasters who I didn't know very well
because they were they joined the
network or the show late and I was
leaving or one foot out the door which
is how I operate and one is Stephen
Colbert yeah and one is Rich Eisen Wow
and I also I thought when I met them I
didn't really know them but I thought
they were good who later became great
bless you credit go great thank you man
but we all there are other groups of us
these some of these interchangeable EPS
right these these guys like ants and
mant and these different guys yes the
Weinberger's I don't they're all
producers from they years ago I was
having coffee with Homer they said is
rich amazing on the NFL Network I said
he's amazing
NFL Network you dominate thanks great
kill you hear that all the time killer
you are very nice to say that and start
this conversation
we're just getting started okay because
again I came at ESPN I arrived at ESPN
turning 40 tomorrow yes bro yes yes yes
p.m. that's right we're celebrating this
later we will be selling me that that
later ourselves because you did not get
an invitation to the ESPN 40th he'll get
something from Al Jaffe
the kingmaker he's the guy who was the
talent hunter if you will he found you
in Salinas California yes Elena Salinas
Santa Cruz Monterey the 110 market you
know how they're numbered yes right it's
the 110 market but it's the most
beautiful market there is I fell in love
I lived in Carmel and I would commute to
Salinas to work right yes sir to be the
clock guy yeah we did 6 and 11 and it
was great what in the hell you like
doing local TV well there was a the guy
who hired me he was the news director
his name was Paul Miller now he owns if
you're ready for this the Carmel pine
cone the newspaper up there
he does very well he's great guy we were
it was the Bay Bridge series the A's and
the Giants on a different network I'm
doing the six o'clock and no one's
watching mm-hmm and and so I did sports
that night and I said no one's if you're
a sports fan you're not watching so for
you non-sports fans I did some kind of
weird thing with the Sun set and
ethereal music we're going down down
down you're a rag doll going down down
down I was just kind of meditating on
the air and and the news director
laughed his ass off and then one of the
reporters go well the right guys laugh
and he thinks it's funny and I was doing
weird stuff back then and then you got
the call from ESPN yes like from there
right yeah yes I was in market I was in
Redding California further up the road
you know reading in reading where'd you
grow up at New York City okay so it was
like new it was like Northern Exposure
look at York Jewish guy in the forest in
the mountains I know and just is the
first time I saw something that large
that wasn't made of garbage you know I
mean it was he was remarkable experience
for me and I got a call from by Al Jaffe
yes
the studio at the station is almost you
know MF Tim to say this has to be a joke
yes and then I showed up and you had
already been there for about three years
well I showed up in 90s my deal was a
three-year deal because I we barely
overlap we'd barely overlapped yes right
so you got there and who was the foot
was the first sport center who did you
do your first sport center with I don't
know if it was Carl Ravich or not but he
was he was the guy very patient with me
right
and so I rather was the guy Robbie was
the guy yeah and by the way I heard your
interview with Ravan
I think we have that can we play this
Kent too low oh you go Mike you have
that go ahead Mike tell Tufo headed you
know I were according to him the real
good addition whatever disclosure I mean
you you of course know Steve Anderson
who was running sports in at the time
about two weeks into the Killa born
ravaged Late Show after Oberon and
Patrick I went into Steve Anderson's
office yeah hose the door and I said
what is this disaster we're burning down
sports Bennett and he to his to his
credit Oh be patient but let's let's
just see where this goes and obviously
as you know you know he became wildly
popular and I was just I was just Felix
to the Oscar I was what do you think
they're okay so exclusive I'm gonna give
you a lot of exclusives everything I say
today is an exclusive for rich eyes
Thank You curriculum
I had a closed-door meeting also with
Steve Anderson is that right I said what
do you think am I being too funny and
Steve Anderson said no bring it on make
me laugh Kilbourne entertainment that
never happened he said Steve Anderson
was a nice guy I just wanted to say I
had a closed-door meeting with Steve
Anders by the way he's a very powerful
man in the management structure yeah
there are other stories there's so many
it's been a long time since you would
say something to me and I would sit here
saying is Craig being serious I just had
a flashback to like 1996 right there I
have news for you even my good friends
don't know when I'm being serious or
being
sarcastic I saw your interview with
greenie the clip of greenie yes boy was
he excited to hear a Kilbourne story
that story about going through the
roaster and again wait we did I think
about three or four sports centers where
again I did one or two first and I did
one before you the first time I ever met
you
oh boy oh boy there you go you're coming
downstairs from the third floor to the
second floor which is the way they go
across a catwalk to the studio you were
going to go track the open as we used to
say back in the day
and I'm going back to the third floor
too because I was just done with a
Sports Center and you said to me nice to
meet you you did call me spark cool you
did call me spark icebreaker you said
you know a lot of what you've just done
you know reminds me of of what I'm doing
so that I who said that I said that am I
saying to you I don't remember these
stories am I saying you're mimicking me
or what am i saying know what to make up
okay like I took it that you were just
messing with me okay couldn't I you're
being sighs I was always I was I was
always into good-natured ribbing yes I'm
a little more mellow now yes slightly
nicer nicer human being we improve as we
get older yes I don't know what I meant
by that but I tell you I don't remember
these stories we have selective memory
you know and and Albert scooter Bertino
was one of my favorite people there he's
at Turner Sports now he's a friend he's
a great guy he mm-hm text me I go I like
sand dabs - he likes sand dabs and all
that goes yes but he tells me a story
that I can't repeat here it wasn't
terrible it was funny when we were
walking down with Steve Levy and Levy
was asked me where I'm gonna live in all
stuff and he tells this story which is
it was kind of a shock joke that I would
do on occasion I I don't remember it but
what I do remember was something a
little more poignant where on my very
first show I was upstairs doing
you know doing the script yeah I think
they may have given me a an extra panel
now on a on a baseball game that I was
really fired up about and so I'm a
little I'm a little rushed and scooter
can see it's my very first show he's
doing prompter yeah and he says hey it's
gonna be okay mm-hmm
and I love that that he was so he was so
supportive sure he I don't know if he
remembers that it meant a lot to me the
only reason I liked him job well you
were you you and I eventually did a show
like about a week later okay and you
came to me and I'll tell the story um I
told really you're like hey let's go
grab some let's go grab something spark
you might have called me that then you
said it the other day I liked hearing
that make a spark you know and come on
let's go get it and and and you drove
and I thought to myself where are we
going I mean I'm going to dinner with
Craig Kilborn who obviously I'd watched
you and and and totally loved everything
that you were doing and I'm like this is
this is the Sports Center experience is
amazing and then we pull up to the Kenny
Rogers role and roaster drive-thru and
you're in the driver's seat and you
proceeded to say that your contracts up
and tell me about the job that you have
on the table and you described the daily
show time yeah and you asked me what do
you think I should do and I I can
remember and of course I bought you
dinner because I do one of my favorite
things to do is to buy the young people
young broadcasters dinner I occasionally
don't buy dinner that's when I charged
an appearance fee what am i but but I
did buy you dinner but I liked I think I
asked because I you're a broadcaster and
I said I wanted someone to say I never
knew if someone was like oh my god yeah
get the hell out of here that sounds so
cool or I don't know I didn't know what
you'd say I just wanted to hear you know
I had no idea what the hell to say well
the only reason I did is because what
you told me the only reason I left is
because Rich Eisen said go man yeah I
did I actually said follow you know what
your gut or follow your dream or
something like that
thank you yes I knew the you know the
rumor was that you you just wanted out
anyway I had done my job I was grateful
for it by the way every job I had I was
grateful for I just wanted to do a
network late-night show that's what I
wanted to do I mean
got it yeah why did you leave it
I've always wanted to ask you that
question I'm gonna give you an exclusive
ok I'm glad it was an easy decision to
leave the CBS show is easily my favorite
show wasn't even closed The Daily Show
was important because there was no way I
was going from ESPN to CBS late-night
right and back in the 90s people forget
this there was a big difference between
cable and network in fact The Daily Show
they developed it because politically
incorrect was leaving to go to ABC
correct
so Daily Show was a blast I was living
in New York but I didn't like the the
format was a news parody four minute
interviews mmm
half-hour show I wanted my hero was
Johnny Carson I wanted to late-night
rail so I do the CBS show 5-year deal
and I lost interest here it is I'm gonna
spell it out because if people don't
understand it some people do get it
somebody it's funny this I don't expect
anyone to understand it but that's fine
but some people do mm-hmm
I won't I'll use the word bored here huh
I say I lost interest in the comedy of
late-night I got bored of the comedy of
late-night mm-hm and I have this weird
irreverent sense of humor whatever it is
and I just didn't want to do it anymore
and I also didn't want to do I don't
want to do social commentary like the
late The Late Show guys now have to do
some politics and social commentary they
write do a great job doesn't interest me
so and it worked out perfectly because
that was kind of for me it was an easy
show to leave you know I'm saying and
there it is did you ever create
Kilbourne ear a couple of the hour with
Craig Kilborn here we're going at an
hour oh yeah brother oh yeah okay yeah
that double scale that's double scale
did you ever communicate that to
Letterman cuz Letterman was the one
before you and he owned he owned this
did I ever communicated that you you
were got bored and you were done did you
lose the word bored because I use it
here because you're pulling it out of me
you're pulling it out of me
and we are pulling yes we are playing
and I are pulling I did call him to set
thank him for the job right and I can
remember one of the things he was but he
was nice he was and I said I I'm a
little I actually did a basketball
reference I said I'm a little nomadic
like Larry Brown because he jumped
around I'm just looking for something
else you know wasn't but I I just didn't
I wanted to do what I got it out of my
system and I was no longer stimulated by
by late-night comedy and and if the
weird thing is and I and I did and I
thought anything I'd want to do is so
narrow that it might not it might there
might not be anything right so I just
said early retirement I like conclusions
boom done and so I wrote this article in
the LA Times where I interviewed myself
in 2015 right and I did it I said this
is the favorite my most favorite thing
I've ever done that's my comedic
Sensibility
and I don't deconstruct it I just I just
do it and the odd thing is I didn't the
Instagram is a little ridiculous it's
even better than the article because
there's some visuals right and it's gone
really well and thank you you're so
supportive and please other go there my
old writer friends on the Alex all canoe
the same Gibby right you know I'm
telling you when we when the cell coup
I've gotten to know Suzy's doing a
project with him too and you know he's
like you got to check out yeah he'll be
on the Instagram and I'm like he's on
Instagram and I started seeing it and it
is for folks who miss you Craig I mean
they'll be very honest it's it's the
it's the good it's the uncut the good
old its hazing it's so much fun it is
fun to do and it's it's everyone by Alex
Salkin my older brother Chris says it's
very positive and Alex kind of like the
little brother I never had who smokes
he's very supportive of it too and I
find it interesting because he's married
he's does Family Guy he's got kids and
he most of the rest of his time 80% 90%
is spent he crushing on Tom Brady he has
a man crush on Tom Brady but he's
spending a little time with me and he's
very encouraging to me and that's enough
on him this is not about
it's not Craig Kilborn everybody and and
we've got we've got Craig here and
student when we come back I want to
stroll down some Sports Center
commercial memory lane with you I've got
a five questions okay can I say one
thing please okay I don't want to
interrupt
even though I just did by the way that's
a great eye I'm looking at everyone and
apologizing yes nice to meet you Chris
same here Craig you're pretty good I'm a
longtime fan I also like to foe
my man over here Ikey what I can see all
cap I have if when you we can do now
we're going to come back sure but I have
the Instagram is gone well there's
there's some prominent DMS I'm only
gonna read three or four but there's
some prominent people have DM me and I
can share them I'd like to share I look
forward to that thank you we've got
coming up for the television only
audience will show you one of Craig's
Instagram videos that we're talking
about we'll come back five questions DM
stroll down Sports Center memory lane
and then later on what this is all
building up to you look great by the
side this is old-school Kilbourne right
now Matt this is fantastic
you look great Craig you know Mike
McQuaid I always did that for Mike
McQuaid he loved when I looked in the
monitor he loved it it's Friday and we
just want to dance dance dance long time
ESPN now producer okay so and then later
on we will toast to SPN yes you and I
will have our own little party that's
Craig Kilborn here on the Rich Eisen
show Craig Kilborn
still with us here on the Rich Eisen
show the rumor was at ESPN when we were
working together and you were there that
basketball was the only sport you cared
about is that a true story
do you agree with that I knew too much
about the NBA I wasn't I'm not proud I'm
not proud of that
no I I did there was and the one thing I
didn't know I didn't memorize years like
the years of the seasons because it was
you know the 85 86 Celtics or I didn't
memorize and one of the research guys
didn't want to go in and look something
up and I didn't know I knew this he said
when the shot clock come and I said 54
55 so even stuff I didn't think I knew I
knew right but I when you when you
followed sports your whole life and
played just you understand all sports I
was into the NFL
I actually played hockey in Minnesota I
played hockey okay you know and then and
the guy the hockey coach says you got to
make a choice between basketball hockey
and and he was trying to be tough he was
in the it was in a little this heating
this heating room near the rink yes with
the team you make a choice and if you're
not gonna be part of the team you walk I
know I said I got to go because I
already knew I was good in basketball I
started basketball in second grade right
but years ago at ESPN Tirico my sweet
man yes took me to a Hartford Whalers
game we're watching the game I said
who's number eight he goes why I said I
like the way he moves he goes it's Jeff
Sanderson fastest skater best passer on
the team I have the vision so the thing
I would say is if you commit to sports
yeah and I remember saying this to
different people if you if you had to be
the voice of the WNBA so you would
immerse yourself yeah yeah I wanted to
do late-night but so I I didn't I didn't
necessarily commit to pierre posh a deep
down no because when i see PA gee that's
Alan page man that's your Minnesota
roots yeah I think broadcasting in
general is is fairly easy that's why so
many people can do it but I'm gonna
complement you again you actually have a
personality you're funny yes thank you
my favorite word when people
mmm charismatic some people are
charismatic I think you're great I
preach I am i Kris am I going too much
complimenting him too much no he likes
hearing about himself we all do there's
an iron-rich and Eisen you know there is
an eye in Kragen well which is Rich's
seems to be a nice guy he is and I did
the driver here I said Richard such a
nice guy the driver today said he is
everyone talks about what a nice guy
Richard hey so that's pretty nice words
out I appreciate that
Tirico took you to the mall huh the
hartford mall yeah somebody you know my
buddy Phil Greene who worked at the I
went to school with and he worked at
ESPN he took me to my first Hartford
Whalers game yeah and I just couldn't
believe it was in the mall yeah I can
actual malls right it was you in Tariq
oh yeah huh Ruth's Chris beforehand you
know you pick up dinner who picked it I
like to buy den
Keio tweeted that you're not on Twitter
right are you under no k keeo tweeted
out that that that you've never bought
dinner for anybody in your life is what
Keith just took Alec sulking out on
Wednesday true story okay I pick my
spots as to Craig Kilborn here on the
Rich Eisen show who shoots your
Instagram videos uh I have I call her my
wife because it's one syllable it's my
longtime girlfriend okay princess cherry
okay who is a she likes it I'd like to
talk about her she doesn't like me to
talk about her but okay she's a hippie
girl okay she's in know they're all the
organic stuff she has a garden it's all
very healthy just won't let me take
statins for my heart I have to take
krill oil okay alright and you know
hippie women love more than anything is
sarcasm so I don't think much at home
but I should I shoot and edit my stuff
unless I need someone else to do it
where I'm not doing this whatever if I'm
dancing or something or moving whirling
at Paris I'm twirling with a parasol yes
be careful so she will shoot that okay
yes and and and so you're in charge of
the desert the dissolving for instance
yeah you're cest with the design she's
loved that when you kid when I saw the
Instagram video of you talking about him
we are dissolving and you get as four
times over and then you dissolve to
Larry Bird a jumper with some Yacht rock
underneath it okay that one that was fun
that's his that's I thought to myself
okay this is the Kilbourne that uh that
we've all been missing this is the Craig
Kilborn that the country one needs
re-injected into her yes we're zeitgeist
thank you you were very welcome thank
you
so you edit you and your your longtime
girlfriend is the one who yes shoot and
then there are certain things I have my
son John will do things that I can't do
like he'll add the twinkle in my eye
there's certain advanced editing but 95%
I it's fun to do and I also I used to in
local TV in Monterey
I went in the Edit Bay and did the
warrior games
let's show Tim Hardaway it's from yo-yo
wave let's show the crossover this is in
the early 90s I did my time my stint in
Redding California 94 to 96 the Mitch
Richmond oh the Run TMC videos that I
edited is well myself by the way have
that history right I Chris Mullin to me
is one of the most underrated NBA ball
players of all time great touch I
remember talking to Freddy Heiberg hmm
Mullen was on the Pacers at the end of
his career and Fred Hoiberg was on that
team and Larry Bird coach did and Fred
said Larry couldn't believe Mullen
because those two guys can shoot Fred
Hoiberg and Larry Bird can shoot yes
Mullen never missed in practice in a
scrimmage he just wouldn't miss a little
flick of the left hand you're talking to
a New York or two I remembered him st.
John's in one of my favorite players did
you ever you did a three-point contest
with Steve Kerr thank you for letting me
does everyone know I get to teach today
I get to teach does everyone know the
difference between excuse and a reason
okay so I'm going to now tell reasons
why I struggled they're not excuses
okay people misuse the word all the time
I had a late night I'm supposed to
referee Kenny Smith and Steve Kerr
mm-hmm they're gonna shoot I'm gonna be
the referee there's four Turner Sports
didn't see I wake up I said god I'm so
glad I don't have to play I'm hurting
back is sore had a late night I all I
have to do is ref they call him they
said Kenny's sick you got a shoot I go
I'm ready I'm ready
so I start warming up and Kerr goes oh
my lord I'm in trouble here because I
you know I I'm I'm a pure shooter but
and and we're not gonna get into the
best part of my game which is passing
okay so only two guys other guys that
can do some of these and that's our
Vitas and Larry but that's that we're
we're not talking about this stay
focused so I I shoot the ball and I miss
every shot on the first rack and I
hadn't played in a long time okay and
then I then I warmed up a little bit on
the second rack and you can see my form
and my release and all that kind of
stuff and in my favorite jump shot is
probably Mark Price I also like Freddie
brown I liked it I like hold that father
well you're sure steve says afterwards
he I lose I didn't I shot you know if I
shoot while I shoot 3 4 5 4 4 5 5 4 5
but he says have you ever pulled the
ball off the rack have you ever pulled
the ball off the rack to practice I said
no he goes well then you got a
practice said I said yeah it's like a
bad pass this is a bad pass you're
supposed to be so I'm pulling it across
my body without ever practicing that's
the reason I missed every shot in the
first round the difference between
learned something today
we did learn professor by the way so the
league did not want me to win I was like
the Sacramento Kings they wanted the NBA
and I don't even know if Steve Kerr
would have recovered from that if he had
lost and if you ever been a coach at the
Warriors but it's a trickle-down bull
see Craig Kilborn here on the Rich Eisen
show I have got some old SportsCenter
commercials I want to play great and
even on the radio it will work as far as
I am concerned because uh Craig Kilborn
let's run through some of your memories
here this is the first one that we have
here is okay Glenn Jacobs oh yeah okay
the original Sparky he was a PA from
ESPN that they decided to put in a
Sports Center commercial because I think
they saw it notice some buy play between
the two year let's take a look my name
is Glenn Jacobson I've been a epi here
Sports Center for about three months and
it's been really great you've
embarrassed me on national TV I work
long hours sure but I get a lot of
exercise that's really cool one of those
guys read something I've written on the
air nice try Sparky nice try
maybe next time four months ago I was
writing a paper about my idol Craig
Kilborn at Gary Glen okay here I am
getting career advice from them two
words for you pizza delivery
it's incredible fantastic oh yeah that
was good how long did you work at ESPN
seven years okay I was there three week
was your you were on the 2:00 a.m. I was
on the 2:00 a.m. well you you dubbed it
the feel good it did yes and then when
you left I did it mostly with Stuart how
was your weight back then not very good
he's mine okay what time would you get
to bed cuz I would get to bed at 4 a.m.
and earlier that's correct and then if I
said oh I liked the show I'm gonna stay
up and watch at 6:30 I get a little
breakfast and then watch it oh my lord
it was not an easy schedule hard I would
agree with ya I saw I saw the Sun Rise
more often than not yeah that is correct
that's what that that commercial around
you of huh that those late night well I
was just I always wanted to know how
over there and I forgot to ask you how
long you were there let's take a look at
the next one this is Bob Lee and Charley
Steiner doing their hard news and then
Craig Kilborn comes in at the end let's
take a look
did he accept the money before the
tournament because if he did I am no
Tyson is fighting where and I know Tyson
is fighting win but I need to know who
that next opponent is going to be what
do you like better hurt me or spank me
[Applause]
those guys were good by the way they
both were very nice but Bob Lee would go
out of his way yes and say I love when
you did you put Barry White in the lead
in he would say that to me Bob Lee was
so supportive he was great Bob Lee you'd
think is you know that he did nickname
the general for enrollees yes so
straight-laced mister you know hard news
he he would come up to me all the time
and say that was a funny leader yeah
it's not like he enjoyed that he's a
nice young man in charge Charlie one of
the greatest sports center commercial
anchors in the history of those
commercials yes where he would did the
the pool boy one for ya know too well
yeah you know and then there's there's
one more here of the pickup game Oh
Cherokee parks and of course wait before
you show it carry one thing yes sure
it's very quick okay it's very quick I
do a hook pass to Juwan Howard yes I
mean you got it you got to see it it's
it was a very quick off the dribble hook
pass yes and he said I didn't know you I
didn't know you had that in your game
companies we've got a team in this
little basketball league being Sports
Center we take it pretty seriously
just play the game plumber boy it's all
good fun directed by the great Hank
Perlman he sees it all so many of them
still a good friend of mine tell him I
said hello or well did you add led the
defense wins championships
did you add little sure I mean I want to
be humble my whole goal in life now is
to be humble yes yes the goal is to be
low-key and improve as we get older you
know I'm saying I appreciate that
first day I came to work at ESPN first
day ever was when you were shooting that
don't walk commercial copy hands across
America so edit me out cuz I left did
you know that no yes Alan Gross was very
upset so the commercial where you came
up with the Ballad don't walk right and
you were front and center yeah and then
I left to go to the comedy central and
they had to edit it out and they were
very upset and I thought one of the
things I wanted to do is apologize for
that I'm sorry
to who who are you apologizing to
whoever was upset ESPN and alan bros I
know Alan doe but he's fine yeah I know
no kidding all right I've got I've got
five questions for you Craig born let's
do it five questions with Craig Kilborn
here on the Rich Eisen
and we got the music and everything is
there crying it in okay here we go
Kilbourne five questions first question
who is Canada's finest actor Craig well
you want me to say Shatner
so I'll say Shatner I'm by the way I'm
not I have not seen these okay so just
as Shatner why I assume it you're
incorrect thank you
question number two where is Krakatoa
located Craig Kilborn east of job that
is correct it's one of your favorite
home run calls number three five
questions third question that was
Della's geography by the way yes number
three what is Robin Williams finest
movie oh well I like dead poet's but I
think the young people like Jumanji it's
correct answer for this question number
four this is my favorite one
say hi to Gus random number four name
this time of year when people get sick
but make a lot of jumpers oh I don't get
this I don't understand this one say it
again name the time of year when people
get sick but make a lot of jumpers the
cold and flu season is correct the cold
and here's number five you can go five
for five you're dining at the sardine
factory in Monterey yeah yes and seared
king salmon with braised asparagus
artichoke and carrots what is the
correct type of wine to order
oh I don't pay attention that I'm sorry
I just do Pinot Noir or a red blend or I
do Cabernet that's correct as you could
see the answer right here whatever he
says is correct Craig Kilborn got five a
five here and then you make sure by the
way the sardine factory they have a nice
picture of Clint Eastwood up there cuz
he one of his movies play misty for me
they had a nice scene right there at the
bar I love that's my favorite
carmel-by-the-sea Monterey Pebble Beach
it's all great so beautiful they're cold
and poo season there
yes how did that start your obsession
with poo Richardson well though I'll
just step back for a second and I'm not
I'm not gonna answer your quick
I'm just having fun I liked his name poo
that's basically it but I wasn't into
catchphrases and the puns I puns they
some people say the lowest form of humor
but it's they're catchy
and unless you're brilliant like Alex
all Coons brilliant and he's really good
at puns so if you're brilliant but so I
have a a friend who is a Oren
acquaintance I'll say who is a software
engineer and boring and not funny but he
can construct puns he can take his
little rhyming dictionary and do that
but that was just I was just he'd score
6 points I wanted to say poo at 2 a.m.
in the morning that's what I I want to
say poo I think it's funny to say how
Auckland dicks I mean who knew haha :
that would be if you were doing yeah
sort centre these days that would be
your guy what about what about the NBA
who would fascinate you now name was do
what you got I don't know name wise
again I'm doing I'm not sure what you
just mentioned the NBA and I just I love
the NBA it's so much it's like talking
about it a little bit I don't have much
to say I do like karl-anthony towns I
will say this just educate people 20
years before the Timberwolves came in
existence in 1989 I was obsessed with
the NBA mm-hm so he'll say is it painful
with the Timberwolves no I like that
there's a team there I always pull for
them but I'm a NBA fan first for 20
years this past championship with
Toronto winning was beautiful loved it
you know I do know it yeah and I dunno I
don't know who's gonna win next year but
there there is a to Sabonis as in the
NBA right now I did not know that kids
of our Vitas is I know I know I know his
son right the Pacers I didn't know about
the other I don't know maybe maybe I'm
I'm just if it feels like there's lots
of Craig Kilborn is here one more
television only segment will sneak in
another view of one of your Instagram
videos and then you're gonna make
martinis for us too okay
no I don't read the thing I'll do that
we'll do that I'm now lost enthusiasm
I'm not doing it your DMC one can read
the end zone we can absolutely do that
we've enough time to read DMS and Clint
glasses that you're gonna make the
martinis to celebrate 40th anniversary
of ESPN see what they're all right Craig
Kilborn is here we've got that when we
return oh this is funny okay let me read
these okay go for it
we're gonna do it right now do it when
we come back Craig Kilborn here on the
Rich Eisen Chris the poll question final
results throw it up there right there
before we get out of Dodge here yeah the
best game of the weekend
LSU Texas 40% how about that beating all
the other wrong NFL games of yesterday
where's Pat's 38% all right a huge story
Craig Kilborn you just read some of the
dm's that you've received on your
Instagram account Oh give me one more
that some famous GM's that you oversee
this is uh Oh Gregory post something
about not retiring can have him around
the house you thought I was boring
Giselle okay let's start this let's get
this so this is allure Lee I don't do
lunch martinis you're pouring a martini
now into the martini shaker I pour just
a little in it looked like there may
have been but you won't complain don't
send the drink back we just need to we
hold the olives are already in the
glasses don't bruise it don't bruise it
some people at home what about stirring
there's a great bar called the Edmund
over on Melrose they like to stir I like
that I like to shake a little bit so are
you more like Bond shaken not stirred or
you first I prefer actually bruising the
vodka make it ice-cold okay you know I'm
saying sir these are vermouth washed
glasses we have put a little vermouth in
there earlier okay and then point it out
okay why don't you take that one take
this is my friend Rich Eisen are we
toasting I just want to toast you seeing
you again you want to toast the s-pen
cream you choke we're toasting to ESPN's
40th anniversary there is a big event
going on this weekend my invitation is
probably where yours is right now yeah
so we just figured why not just do it
ourselves what a nice thought you don't
mean like
I haven't seen you in a very long time I
was getting I know I like to toast I
haven't seen you in a long time
Craig and I you know I've been
cultivating this caper to try and get
you come on this show and what if I only
do your show I'd love to just do that
because I like your your smooth and
natural that icon you I like rich there
you like rich okay I need just see what
this is cuz we shot the ice was sitting
there cheers to you nice to see you soon
nice to finally meet you
Cheers mmm it's watered down don't say
anything it's watered down its but it's
funny that's because the ice was sitting
there below but let's pretend it's not
this is what I say mmm at a bar or
restaurant the big four up in San
Francisco and Nob Hill I take a sip I go
like this I go this is the greatest
moment of my life I enjoy the moment
this is now the greatest moment of my
life when I take a sip of a beautiful
chilled Whatcom I need fresh ice we're
gonna do it again offer off the away but
the vodka does taste appropriately
bruised by the way and it feels it's and
it was made with love yeah I felt I felt
when I thought when I poured the Viking
there I saw that it went up to I knew
there was water in there from the ice
melting that's okay I don't want to go
I'm not complaining but we didn't have
to say anything and I was the one who
said it because I thought you might it
is just the most special moment in my
life here we go well you're choosing
again or no I'm just gonna sip again I
just this mic is in my way okay here we
go it's hard to drink it's why it's hard
to drink with the mic in here okay we go
Craig Kilborn here on the Rich Eisen
show show be music
mm-hmm very good know it don't worry
about it Mike don't worry about there's
a greatest moment in history just a fun
moment we've heard the name Pooh
Richardson Cherokee parks you mentioned
Mike Zimmer you love Mike Zimmer you
love biking yeah I mean there's a lot of
good teams the NFC I don't know maybe
you could explain I know how they play
different divisions out you know but I
don't know how they choose home in a way
and if we had the Rams schedule I would
we're in the playoffs maybe in the NFC
Championship game I like our defense
offensive line has to improve Cousins is
a big question mark I like the receivers
I like Diggs when he was a rookie and
now he's a big star I like Dalvin cook
are kicking his suspect but maybe maybe
it's average or okay but we did you love
Mike Zimmer of course he cares about his
first year with the Vikings they went
seven and nine they could have gone
eight and eight they gave up a third and
23 at Buffalo they blew it last game in
the season press conference he got
emotional he cares and he said Savior
Rhodes came up and said you've made me a
better football player because he was
hard on Xavier I love Mike Zimmer
there's no reason to sue you about okay
thank you thank you for letting me talk
about Mike Zimmer is one of the all-time
favorites around here it's good to see
you Craig thank you sir so will you come
back or you should come back I'll come
back yes I will come back and what about
ten years playoffs no no no okay yeah I
got a little taste it does we don't have
to drink a water day Bob you don't have
to every time this is just for the hot
happy 40th anniversary ESPN from me and
Craig Kilborn how is that sound that's
beautiful are you are you stretching
right now I'm and we are stretching and
we are stretching and dissolve and we
are dissolved can we get one dissolve
come on give me a dissolve before
just crank at the saw and we are
dissolving have a great weekend
everybody on eyes and overtime will give
you sneaky good games and also my take
on that Tonio brown for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app